[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zur welt das video
war eigentlich gar nicht geplant aber
wir haben hunger und des zeitpunkts
ausprobieren jetzt ich kenne jetzt
bekannte leute die das essen und jetzt
ist er mir gezeigt du kannst mir zeigen
wie man das macht und ich habe das
gefühl
dann werde ich ein besserer moderator
bärenstark und denken sie was um
goldkehlchen ja eine person wissen wir
alle wer jeden tag porridge ist kein
berner da ist wirklich jeden fall falsch
ich muss immer fragen was macht er doch
selber oder macht er das er arbeitet
unglaublich mit irgendwelchen coolen
jungen leuten weis mit mega game sind
unsere drei bären soll beflügeln das
match mein gott es hieß ein so früher
haferbrei haferbrei wir machen heute
haferbrei und wir essen das auch echt
gerne denn zum einen sättigt ist es ist
lecker es ist gesund und ziemlich
proteinreiche auch und einfach nicht so
schnell wieder alles neu trainieren
wir müssen jetzt danach nicht echt waren
das perfekte frühstück von miguel war
eine runde schneller als ich war seit
ihr um den teich ohne see ums feld
daneben das war eine kilometer und dann
habe ich irgendwann nicht mehr gesehen
und dann dachte ich mir so und jetzt
brauche ich dringend wasser weg macht
also deswegen gibt es jetzt ja und das
kann man zum einen abend vorbereiten zur
overnight mail oder man kann es eben
ganz frisch zubereiten jedenfalls gibt
es eigentlich grob gesagt kein rezept
dafür denn ihr nehmt einfach die zutaten
direkt zum einfach die haferflocken und
wasser
ich kochte auch immer mit wasser auf
denn wenn man mit milch kocht dann
bremst immer ganz schnell an der wand
auf power boost macht und was haben wir
noch mal auch hilft
ich ergänze mit mandeln
bei den mantel mail auch einfach super
protein reich ist und es sind natürliche
pflanzliche proteine und das ist echt
mega lecker der kameramann hatte
unterarme man ja sowieso schon immer
kurz dass moskau als sehr gesund da noch
mehr obst
die sind aus unserem garten dann habe
ich hier noch es gehe also so ein
milchprodukt ist auch super
proteinreiche für die jungen leute
man kann aber auch vegan was nehmen und
ich nehme mir auch so hat es das ist
lecker menschen das jetzt gebe ich habe
ihm fünf kilo einmal davon das macht
sich durch mandl trenne man bequem ohne
zucker und ich mache das immer so nach
tasten prinzip also so 50 gramm
haferflocken pro person reichen schon
immer meine kleine im alter fit ist und
wir sehen jetzt zu zweit also nicht eine
tasse dann haben wir dann haben wir noch
die ihn und so geil oder oh mein gott
gut oder sehr lecker das ist schon
lecker halt alles was ich glaube ich die
letzten wochen zum frühstück gegessen
habe schon nicht schlecht
drei tassen für sechs personen und jetzt
muss ich
mal vier die wassermenge 3 x 4 12 also
ich werde es noch dran sagt erhielt 3
ich mach mal okay also ich mache das
immer direkt aus den flaschen
du machst du teller ich würde da so eine
hörende hinlegen ich muss sagen willst
so wenn ich jetzt kein rezept video
machen würde würde ich jetzt auch nicht
abmessungen zu augenmaß
ich habe auch nicht mehr mitgezählt
solange leid ich hatte denke mein gott
auf eine halbe tasse haferflocken geht
eine tasse wasser okay denn glaube ich
höre ich durch dann ja dann ist richtig
dann war es richtig
ok also halbe tasse auf eine tasse
wasser und jetzt einfach erwerben und so
ein bisschen rühren und wir können ja
auch schon mal in der zeit morgens
dauert es extra so fünf minuten oder 10
mg für die ganze das ganze team
das sehen wir dieses wunderschönen
schneidewind
[Applaus]
aber chance aber platziert wichtig bin
lokal produziert amazing bambus wie
möchte das denn dienste grammel oder
instagram okay ist mit entspannten ja ja
wollte ich genau so erledigen ja so und
dann und dann so aus der mitte heraus
genau 34 stück ja so schön dünn weil man
ist dass er im löffel hat dann kein
messer zur hand
dann muss man es mit einem hab's schon
so ich lass dir das nicht entkernt ja
das kann ich sehr gut es geht übrigens
besser wenn die reifen sind aber die
sind noch nicht so ganz
aber dafür sind die messer hierher
schafft das kenne ich uns auch nicht gut
ich habe auch mal was
hast du lust hast du einen guten messer
schleift jetzt hier auch so
ich habe jetzt schon einfach recht
machst du das hobbymäßig oder ist es so
ist es eine berufung hat ein bisschen
nacht ausgebrochen war so schleifen
das 2,3 ist fertig das ist schön ich
wäre das eingedeckt hat marius so sieht
es jetzt aus was auch nicht bei höchster
stufe sondern wirklich mit der hitze sie
haben man muss halt sagen viele haben
viele haben ein haferbrei eine phobie
matschie ich habe immer bereit dann auch
noch gekriegt muss man täglich
ich hab das nie bekommen ja ich habe
erst spät angekommen ist früchte gezeigt
ich packte jetzt noch diese mancher
rhein gibt geschmack protein und jetzt
nehmen wir hier noch dem spiel und am
ende passte sich auch in hama geschmack
und vor allem süßes dass man so die
grundlage dass mal ist sehr durchdacht
ernsteren ja und ich wollte halt
weißt du was es ist glaube ich mir geld
was das hier ausmacht ich bin mir sehr
sicher ich glaube jetzt rausgefunden wie
gestern ganz lange miteinander geredet
aber ich bin mir bei einer sache sicher
ich war schon bei julien und ich weiß
bei dir und eine sache habt ihr wirklich
gemeint und das sind crocs am eingang
für die gäste und ich glaube tatsächlich
dass ist das geheimnis nicht das ganze
drum leute der zauber ist wunderschön
und das stimmt auch also ich war hier
ich bin ich bin verzaubert das für mich
mit diesen world hier gerade aber die
crocs geschichte das ist glaube ich der
weg zum erfolg
also wenn ihr irgendwie was aufbauten
lokale bäckerei cox am eingang einfach
mal meister und vor allem in tacen
das wird nichts bekommen habe kein
hochrhein im rein sportlich jungen agil
für was steht er weiß ja selber nicht
genau aber
[Musik]
jetzt hat auch bisschen warm der höhe
vorbei
langsam wie ich merke schon dass er
gesagt hat da einer die karaoke bin
traurig läuft gedrückt machte heilige
mutter hat er den clown
doch die traurigen augen mein gott er
hat den terror krieg noch einmal hinein
regieren weil sie auf gar keinen fall
wurde mit 88 8
ich hatte mich ich möchte mich im namen
der belegschaft entschuldigen maxi
clausen und zu verteilen
so etwas hatte ich noch drauf bestimmt
so sehen die flocken oder so was nie
irgendwelche irgendwie irgendwas noch
nicht an ist also ja ich kenne es auch
nur von den sowjets durch sohn und dem
gegessen deswegen ich hätte einfach auf
ich mache noch gemeinsam tragen
sie müssen eigentlich woche gestartet
werden also am besten die leinsamen
vorher schrooten
warum schroth und money for her damit
die ballaststoffe und die nährstoffe in
deinem körper dringen aber wenn man das
ist dann schon ein bisschen mit der
meinung nämlich auch so und gefrorene
früchte sehen auch immer hübsch aus aber
belassen
apa
ich probiere so alle bestandteile zu
sein sind oder machst du direkt zu sagen
ich mache jetzt erstmal den joghurt ich
traue mich langsam ran
das größte nur lecker und süßer mag
nimmt noch eine banane und trifft die
rein oder ohne strom ohne abgaben
dicksaft auch das urteil hat der zucker
und dann nämlich wenn es also für die
kinder mache ich den hv preise drückt
noch eine banane rein und gibt dann
ungesüßten cacau drauf und dann denken
die jetzt der schock prozent treibt noch
im april dazu brauchst du süßer
ich würde für probieren erst mal ich
glaube ich brauche nicht süßer bis dann
bis dann der fruchtzucker weg ist weiß
und dann und dann würde ich glaube daran
anpassen könnte man nicht auch eine
dattel nehmen oder sollen die der
überschneiden
datteln nehmen ich finde alles gut was
so keinen extra industrie zukommen
das stimmt lieber mal wieder bei dem bei
den basics beim er sonnt sich reife
bananen und das so oder so sagte börner
wann ist man würde das macht mir sind
wenn man berühmt ist das ist einfach es
ist da und man denkt sich so warum geht
man nicht die extra meile noch mehr zum
apfel allein die frauen ist so ja es
macht keinen sinn also ist möglich auch
nur eine kopie muss man ersatzweise
unser konzept das war's und basis rezept
was ihr einfach abwandeln könnt und dann
könnt ihr uns eure wunderschönen
brauchitsch bilder zeigen auf instagram
und uns verlinken und dann gucken wir
sie an kommentieren jedes einzelne alle
schleck auch ganze dann sag ich mir
immer eins mehr
also viel spaß bis zum nächsten mal
aber so ein richtig ist wirklich zu
verstehen muss man auch mal machen gerne
gerne und brotbacken gerne
gutes essen das normal laufen
[Musik]
[Applaus]